when I was 16 I walked into this bookies
that's put a bet on a football match and
while I was waiting for my friend they
put a few pounds in the machine and 120
quid playing roulette and over the next
few weeks our won a thousand pounds and
this set off the spiral of addiction
which cost me in the region of 20,000
pounds and nearly my life as a student
here in Birmingham I was using these
machines everyday it's taking hundreds
of pounds at a time at this specimen
shop I've had the addiction by working
more hours or borrowing I gambled my
student load in hours I sold all my
possessions online and I was on the
brink of dropping out I hit rock bottom
and contemplated taking my own life it's
not just me fix those betting terminals
affect lives across the country
these machines highly addictive because
they have a very high stake and you can
lose money fast people think that you
can win money quickly and it feels like
that when you're playing but actually we
see continually that people lose money
very very fast get into a position where
they feel they need to get it back they
can't tell their family and other people
what they're doing and they get stuck
and trapped in 2001 bookies introduced
roulette and casino games to their high
street shops a loophole in the law
allowed them to claim there were lot
betting on a horse race so they called
them fixed odds betting terminals
regulators feared a legal challenge and
created a fudge the machines could stay
limited to four in each shop with a
maximum stake of a hundred pounds of
spin Labour's 2005 gambling act cemented
a deal now highly addictive casino games
on the high street and making the
bookies close to 2 billion pounds a year
money spent on fix old betting terminals
isn't recirculated into the local
economy means that they effectively cost
jobs compared with other things that
people might spend their money on even
compared with other forms of gambling
research we did suggested that for every
billion pounds that spent on fictional
betting terminals per year that reduces
employment by about 16,000 jobs a year
so their jobs story is essentially there
are twice as many betting shops in the
poorest boroughs than the most affluent
and they appear in clusters to maximize
the number of machines local authorities
are powerless to stop new openings here
in noon there are multiple betting shops
on this one street
now the council here is join forces with
ninety-three others to demand that the
government reduced the maximum state to
two pounder spin
studies show that two and every five
people who use fixed odds betting
terminals are with a problem or at-risk
gamblers and that rises to four in five
would give about thirteen pound forces
spin or more reducing the maximum state
to two pounder spin would significantly
reduce the harm associated with them as
someone who nearly lost everything to
these machines and I don't know made a
huge difference to me the government
must act now